[Música]
les doy la bienvenida al espacio de
cultura de France 24 mujer vida libertad
Este es el lema de revuelta que corrían
las iraníes desde hace casi un mes el
símbolo de este movimiento masa a mini
de 22 años detenida el 13 de septiembre
por la policía de la moral por un mechón
de pelo que sobresalía de su velo su
muerte de tres días después provocó un
levantamiento popular sin precedentes y
duramente reprimido por el régimen iraní
pero a pesar de los intentos del
gobierno por acallar las protestas el
número de participantes va en aumento y
junto a ellos los artistas de la
diáspora ponen en prácticas sus
habilidades para amplificar la voz del
pueblo nuestros colegas de la cadena
francesa hablaron con la escritora magia
majiy sobre el reto de seguir
movilizando al público internacional la
escuchamos
creo que el silencio La indiferencia o
el olvido solo servirán a régimen
islámico iraní
por ejemplo cortar internet es una forma
de no dejar salir nada del país
por eso es muy importante como hizo
Llamar al apoyo y a la solidaridad sobre
todo de parte de los artistas porque
somos nos guste o no los portavoces de
este movimiento
no podemos permanecer en silencio no
podemos fingir que nos está produciendo
una revuelta sin precedentes así que
tenemos que hablar tenemos que denunciar
tenemos que llevar la palabra de las y
los iraníes al extranjero Y muy lejos
ciertos artistas eligen utilizar su voz
para apoyar luchas y causas durante toda
su carrera es el caso de la cantante
belga axelhead que trabaja con la ong
jumanji tiene incluyen desde los años 90
una organización que tiene como misión
mejorar las condiciones de vida y
promover el respecto de la dignidad de
las personas con discapacidad y de las
poblaciones vulnerables en el marco de
los 40 años de humanity quien incluyen
axelhead viajó por primera vez a
Colombia en el tolima y en la guajira
para conocer entre otras cosas los
proyectos de asistencia a las víctimas
de violencia y de Educación en zonas de
riesgo de minas antipersonales un apoyo
fundamental para poder después dar
testimonio en Europa de las
problemáticas de estas comunidades como
lo explican la cantante y Marta
Gutiérrez El jefa Regional de proyecto
en Europa no saben lo que está pasando
en Colombia o la respuesta humanitaria
que estamos dando estas organizaciones
entonces para nosotros es fundamental y
apreciamos mucho que artistas como Axel
puedan venir y puedan ver los problemas
que hay puedan ver también cómo se
pueden solucionar y puedan ser nuestra
voz allí donde nosotros no podemos
llegar como hace
para mí es más que ser un artista estoy
comprometida con la condición humana y
si no hubiera sido artista quiero decir
soy abogada de formación me habría
dedicado la labor humanitaria de todos
modos
bueno así que traigo mi Piedrecita un
poco como todo el mundo hace aquí
y siempre me digo cuando estoy muy
decepcionada y cuando pierdo la
confianza en los humanos a veces o
cuando me digo Oh cada vez Hay nuevas
crisis merece la perfección
me digo que de hecho si todo todo el
mundo añade su Piedrecita podemos
progresar
y creo que realmente estamos avanzando
creo que cada vez más gente es
consciente de que podemos cambiar las
cosas
así que hagámoslo
vamos a hablar ahora de un documental
que cuenta la fabricación de un
monumento de la música brasileña el
disco Ellis y toma Los Ángeles febrero
de 1974 Elis Regina una de las voces más
poderosas de jazz de la época y Tom
jobín considerado el padre de la bolsa
Nova y que ya había grabado su famoso
the Girl from ipanema con Frank Sinatra
se reúnen y graban un disco que cambiará
sus vidas un cineasta registró todo el
proceso y la persona que lo contrató es
también el responsable de este encuentro
musical histórico el mismo director del
documental Roberto de oliveira nuestras
corresponsales variarías zakoni y Julia
lo entrevistaron en el marco del estreno
mundial del documental en el Festival
Internacional cine de Río de Janeiro
fue grabado en 16 milímetros reversibles
que era una tecnología recién surgida en
aquella época que no necesitaba pasar
por el negativo
surgió en función de la televisión de
los Estados Unidos que precisaba revelar
rápidamente el material
y nos quedamos un poco preocupados con
la duración de este material que quedó
guardado durante 45 años pero la calidad
del filme es excelente no se deterioró
está muy bien
Yo en aquella época sabía que estaba
haciendo un encuentro histórico el álbum
también se convirtió en un disco
histórico
y por suerte el material se preservó muy
bien
Nos despedimos con una de las canciones
más míticas de este álbum aguas jimaso
Gracias a ustedes por su confianza y
sigan con nosotros hay más cultura en
Ramos 24 y France 24.com
[Música]